i want to tell everybody why i think uh
the first
and most important reason i think
freedom phone
could actually be very very good very
very important and why the establishment
is probably coming after you so hard
first let me say i have not tested the
device
i have not done a forensic analysis on
it i would like to get some of our tech
experts to crack it open go through it
hardware and software and see if it can
actually do what we think it can do
that's no problem at all there are some
concerns about whether or not there will
be some chinese spyware perhaps because
you know it's made in china whatever
maybe there's concerns that there's data
leakage in some capacity that it's
spying on you some people are saying
it's a honeypot that the feds are
funding this to get all of the patriots
to use the phone and they can track
everything you do and i'm like they do
that through google and apple yeah
they're called national security letters
if you're worried about your phone being
spied on you are literally in the nsa
database with your existing phone that
can't get any worse they're already
spying on you but here's the thing
why are all these outlets freaking
out anti-censorship as a service
so when daily beast comes out and says
this is a cheap device it's garbage when
gizmodo says it should be avoided at all
costs i'm like what are they really
freaking out about
most people
cannot get an android device jailbreak
it and and and flash it with whatever
you know boot it up whatever uh
operating system they want i'm seeing a
bunch of people on twitter and they were
like you could just put graphene os on
it so for those that are not familiar
with this you know maybe i don't get too
jargony
phones come with the android operating
system android phones do then usually
there's some like skin or bloatware that
a company will put into it so like
samsung has their specific version
you can actually plug it in hook it up
your computer erase that and put a fresh
new clean operating system and many
activists and hackers have created
anti-censorship and they've created you
know free speech and anti-tracking
and um even like even operating systems
that erase themselves a certain period
of time
they've created these things to enhance
individual rights and and security
i would say
99.9 of people would never figure out
how to do that i know people like you
you sure you can pull up a youtube
tutorial like here's how you make your
phone secure and sensor free
all of a sudden you pop up and you're
like just to buy this it's done
so what where is that where's that money
so so they they try claiming that it's a
cheap knock off
okay well you've got a custom operating
system on it
even if it just loaded up a sensor free
store that'd be worth it
an app store that has apps on it that
google and apple don't like
so if you want to choose what you
consume you can
the reason i think this is so dangerous
is that it gives the opportunity
assuming it works again like i said i
didn't try it i'm not endorsing it i'm
just saying the concept
the average person who cannot make a
device can just buy one and have it and
assuming it does what you claim it does
this is really really dangerous for the
establishment that wants to track people
they don't want you to shut down we
already know we got the stupid amazon
robot spying on us we already know that
the smartphones have their microphones
on
we know that the nsa is is incidentally
uh collecting all this information i
shouldn't even say incidentally glenn
greenwald exposed x key score the things
they're doing with bulk data collection
so if you can buy a device that's not
connected to those networks you're still
going to get spied on very likely
through just general cell networks where
your phone is with what it's connected
to let me guys tell you guys something i
got an alert on my phone
and it said you know maryland tracking
how do they know that my phone's in
maryland how what because listen
of course they know where my phone is
right
but what gives them the right to share
it and act upon it and that's where it
gets really weird my phone number is a
new york city number
i am not uh uh my primary residence is
not maryland i am in maryland
my phone alerts and says maryland
information on covet and tracking and
all that stuff and that means that the
cell company has given my data to the
maryland government or at the very least
the cell company is acting upon my data
at the behest of a government program
yeah i'm not a fan of that i never
consented to them alerting my phone
based on location in that capacity but
you know what amber alerts presidential
text messages they know where you are
they're tracking you all the time
if regular people can get access to a
device that adds even one percent or 0.1
to their privacy and their free speech
that's going to be a real threat to the
machine which is trying to eliminate
this ideology classical liberalism the
right whatever
if they are slowly eroding uh free
speech banning people on twitter banning
people on facebook banning people on
youtube and then all of a sudden someone
can just pay money and get a device that
immediately puts a halt to that
operation
how do what are they going to do send a
bunch of muggers to go steal your phone
they can't do that
so you look at what youtube twitter and
facebook are doing with banning hate
speech promising to do more to clean up
and end the rabbit holes and then all of
a sudden you get a phone and you can
talk to whoever you want
so like i said we'll have to actually
you know before i actually say it's a
good device i'll get you phones and you
can tear it apart rip it apart we've
tested but we're not gonna take the
phones from you oh well get them
so what our plan is no bias then get
them right so once you ship the phones
we will reach out to people and randomly
select phones for testing do it oh yeah
perfect yeah that's perfect not not
through you because look if i went to
you'd be like oh here's the phone and
then we'd be like it's perfect it's
great oh you're right you're right
attention phones yeah exactly no
randomly get some and all that happy to
put it to the test
but anyway
when we're hearing what what with it
bind administration is doing with
censorship
with the text messages and you know like
yeah i mean seeing an article come out
like right before we launched our phone
about how they're pressuring phone
companies to uh
uh to like get you know prevent the
spread of misinformation in your text
messages i mean it's sick i mean that
you know if you're texting your mom or
your your father your daughter your son
i mean it's it's it's terrible like what
they're doing could you imagine if you
were talking on the phone to your mom
and then you said something and it just
cut the phone off yeah like twitter you
get a label for misinformation right i
mean it's maybe you get that in text
message you know maybe you get like a
amber alert while you're on the phone or
something your personal phone number
you're talking to your your mother on
the phone and they they blockade you
from being able to communicate that's
insane at least they had the decency to
lie before and say they weren't
monitoring you um or at least the
decency to say it was for your safety
but now it's just so blatant we've made
the argument for a long time that social
media networks should operate like
phones
and we would use that point as an
example as to how shocking it would be
should they actually do that we'd be
like you know twitter should be like a
common carrier like they shouldn't be
censoring what i say could you imagine
if you texted your mom and your tweet
your text got deleted i mean that'd be
crazy and now we're here and they're
doing it yeah or at least there's rumors
it's happening but they've stated they
are doing it well from the press you
know from the white house the press
secretary's podium i mean that they're
saying they're doing it i mean it's
right or they're pr want to do it they
said that they're they're working in
conjunction with the dnc and phone
companies to what do they say uh meet
out misinformation
but there have been rumors from people
saying that they've tried sending texts
and the texts don't go through on
certain issues yeah but that's something
i can't confirm but i don't know if i
have to considering the white house says
this is what they're doing or at least
that's their intention they're actively
working in this direction
and they said that they're actively
flagging things for facebook in which
case
it's happening isn't it yeah exactly i
mean it's it's
that's the thing is the internet was the
biggest
uh uh the biggest weapon in the in the
fight against
um
just hoaxes honestly and uh and you know
obviously it spread some you know you
could but i think it's a net good
because you're not able to do
hoaxes like wmds in iraq anymore and uh
and because of social media because of
the yeah but they did russia yeah they
did they did and i i think you would
have seen the number the poll numbers on
people believing that
uh way higher if you didn't have the
internet i don't know i feel like it's
it's uh you know in a sense easier and
harder with the internet to do these
large-scale hoaxes right they just make
a fake video
there was a video i covered years ago
where
uh some video footage got leaked and i
think it was in iraq there was a news
report from
i think it was like cnn the bbc
and they were like
bomb blast goes off people injured
and then someone leaked footage where
you see a car blow up and then a bunch
of people run into frame lay on the
ground and start writhing and painting
wow wow so i don't know what that was
you don't know who staged it for all we
know russia could have made a stage that
claiming it was staged by someone else
you see the point like you never know
who's trying to manipulate false false
flag exactly
a false flag false flag oh snap
making me nervous false flagpole does it
go the inception i don't know where that
video is from you know you see you see
the car explode you see people run up
after the fact lay down and act as
though they were in the blaster
we don't know what it was from but it
does call into question the initial
reporting because the reporting talked
about the people who were there in the
blast and then you see the blast you're
like uh
well at least that story is not true so
why is why is it being pushed out
the i say it's easier and harder it's
easier in a sense that you've got to do
the hard work of making fake content
hiring people to run the sock puppet
accounts
but then you have a substantially larger
reach in terms of that kind of
manipulation you know
i didn't even know what fiat currency
was until 2007 when i saw zeitgeist or
eight or whatever i went to school in
the united states grew up in the 90s and
the 80s we've been on fiat currency
since 1970 71 or something i was i never
even heard the phrase fiat currency i
was never taught that never explained
that they can print as much as they want
until the internet mm-hmm they found a
way to tax you without you realizing
yeah and if the internet had not come
around and
opportunities like zeitgeist had not
been presented i would still not know
probably it's crazy crazy
yep and now
they're slowly taking those those rights
and those freedoms away i mean look at
the internet where it was in the late
90s you could find wacky crazy stuff
gosh banged up dot com i mean you would
probably still find that it was just
dirt dirty
dirty death porn no no
yeah but that's exactly the point i mean
uh the stuff you'd see on live league
now yeah live league but now and take a
look at like torrenting and take a look
at like the height in the ten years ago
what happened with kim.com you remember
that yeah what did happen what went down
with that he had so so let me break it
down for you the where the wild west of
the internet was mega upload was a file
locker you would open you set up account
and then you'd say i want to store my
files here just like google if you're on
google drive you can upload a video and
look it's your kids doing it you run
around the yard or whatever
and then you can share the link with
your friends so they can download it
it's an easy way for people to just all
download something at once and send it
to everybody well the problem was people
started immediately using a mega upload
to post movies
and tv shows and it was just almost like
i think more than half of it was piracy
a lot of people were using it but piracy
well kim.com a new zealand businessman
who had who has never been to the us
had like i guess us um
i think it was the the um was it the
mpaa
motion picture association of america i
could be wrong but like some american
industries and the fbi i think it was
the fbi and new zealand authorities raid
his home and arrest him in like the
middle of the night or whatever he's the
super rich guy and they claimed it was
like piracy whatever
i interviewed kim.com for uh vice and he
made a really really interesting point
because i was like i was trying to
challenge i'm like why wouldn't you take
these things down
why weren't you deleting the movies when
they were uploading piracy and he said
are we supposed to go into our users
accounts and spy on them are we supposed
to start reading through their file
names to see what they uploaded and why
we did take them down he was like when
we would get sent links and say this is
piracy we would delete them immediately
but
proactively that would mean someone
would create an account and we'd have to
go into their account
look at what they're uploading and then
even watch the video to make sure
because people can name videos whatever
they want and then he was like it's not
something we could do but we were
actively telling them we will do it it
didn't matter they came in they shut it
all down
the point of the story is ten years ago
the internet was the wild west every
movie every show you can watch anything
anywhere and they've done a really good
job
doing two things shutting all that down
the piracy and actually making it a lot
easier to watch movies so people be
honest i got no problem paying 10 bucks
a month so i can get a big library of
movies and have to worry about viruses
and garbage links and there have been
times where it's like i'd see a movie
and someone sent me a link and i'd be
like oh cool you know an independent
stand and click it and then it would be
some like weird rom-com like wrongly
labeled or something i'm like this is
dumb i just want to watch the movie so
they created streaming services it was a
great improvement in my opinion but the
point is what what happened with the end
of the wild west how everything became
more streamlined like channels we're
seeing that happen now with social media
as well you know i really don't like the
term piracy when you talk about copying
information maybe illegally on the
internet or whatever but copying
information because a pirate would steal
your thing and then you wouldn't have it
anymore a pirate didn't come and copy it
down and then take a copy of it and
leave you with your original the pirate
piracy is stealing making a copy of
something is different than that i
disagree oh it's it's completely
different than stealing it's it's
i had friends who worked in the movie
industry who are losing their jobs
because they they would they would spend
like you know a couple hundred grand on
doing like a low-budget feature and then
it would immediately get pirated and
then they'd be like guys we turned zero
profit we can't do this anymore sorry i
know people in the trucking industry
they're losing their job modern
technologies altered the way we
communicate it's it's not piracy that's
the point i i disagree we can't redefine
piracy to make people look like villains
and make it seem like they're stealing
when they're making a copy of something
it's different
but i think they are stealing
you could argue that because of
copyright law but that didn't exist
until like 1600 or something well
piracy happened after that too oh yeah
piracy has been happening for a long
time before
i i was never i i was never of the
opinion that people should be allowed to
just copy any bit of information they
that they wanted in the sense that like
you don't need to give someone
it it's i don't even understand how this
is an argument like if you are if you
believe in the in the rights of the
working class to be able to have someone
like let's let's let's think about like
an invention or designing a structure
someone sits there and tries to figure
out how to make this object work how to
design this engine properly and then
you're like i can copy it you can't do
anything about it and you're like dude
i've worked for 10 years to design this
and like we don't care yeah i'm not
stealing it i'm just duplicating right
but if they try and sell it now they're
on the hook for illegal activity but
copying it is
human rights and then copying and
everyone gets to use it and and so the
issue the issue there is i certainly
like the idea that if someone invents
something or makes something that can be
easily shared and everyone can enjoy the
fruits of of of that product i like the
idea they can but then to say that the
person who broke their back
worked really really hard to make that
gets nothing for it no that's a problem
if i so say you made something uh data
and i copied it and then sold it i think
it should be written into the code that
if i get paid you get paid
a large amount because you're the
creator of the content so what you need
to understand about the content that was
being taken was that the consumption of
the content was happening on mass scales
with millions of people who did not pay
for it
so shouldn't the person who made it
allowed to be compensated for the fruits
of their labor
i think artists should be able to make
money you know unless and if they want
it to be available for free they can you
know they can have a license where it's
available to people you know put it on
the open domain thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time